inició esta mañana la primera audiencia
de la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos sobre la criminalización
absoluta del aborto en sus tribunales de
San José en Costa Rica escuchará durante
dos días el caso Beatriz y la demanda de
sus familiares contra el estado de El
Salvador por presuntas violaciones de
sus derechos Beatriz era una joven
salvadoreña de 22 años que fue obligada
a llevar un embarazo Aunque su vida
corría peligro y que el feto se estaba
desarrollando sin cerebro la joven
padecía de lupus la misma enfermedad que
también padece una de las juezas de la
corte idh por lo que hoy se expuso de
conocer el caso las organizaciones
feministas esperan que esa audiencia
marque un presidente en Latinoamérica
Por qué Porque podría presentar una
posibilidad para que el Salvador
despenalice el aborto terapéutico ya que
la sentencias de la corte idh el
carácter obligatorio para los estados
que forman parte de la oea la
organización de los Estados Americanos
recordemos que en El Salvador las
mujeres que aborten aunque sea de manera
involuntaria involuntaria pueden ser
procesadas bajo el cargo de homicidio
agravado sin embargo Al iniciar el
juicio el presidente de la asamblea
legislativa del Salvador Ernesto Castro
tuiteó que no existe ni la mínima
posibilidad de que se despenalice el
aborto en su país